Only the first answer is correct. In Call of Duty and World of Warcraft, and
many other video games, you move through a 3D world and interact with it.
Pixar's Toy Story was the first film made completely with computer graphics back
in 1995. It and many other animated films, such as the Ice Age series, use 3D
rendering techniques. However, the final product is not interactive. It's a
linear film that you have no real control over. Each image in a computer
animated movie can take from seconds, to minutes, to hours to compute depending
on the complexity of the scene. That said, artists and technical directors
working on these films depend on interactive rendering techniques to set up
lighting, design materials, and create animations. Computerized tomography or
other 3D image techniques gather slices of data. However, gathering the data by
performing the scan is not the same as rendering this data. Pacman is
interactive and is rendered, but the scene described is entirely in 2D. Games
such as Angry Birds are also in this category where an illusion of 3D is
achieved by having 2D layers that move at different speeds. Mobile phones and
tablet's can certainly perform 3D rendering, but these particular games don't
need such capabilities.